what's weird about Skin Walkers they  were all happening there you know so you  have all these things happening in one  location but as Jim said it's like super  elusive  um it's almost like it'll watch you be  there for a week and then the night  you're driving away to go home it's like  you look in your rear view mirror and  there's something crazy you know and it  almost toys with you that was something  that they all seem to say like it seemed  like it knew that you wanted to see  something you want to do something  whatever what I find fascinating is that  you have this one location where so many  things are happening and it's documented  by a bunch of government people a bunch  of PhD scientists a bunch of people that  have lived there and  um and not only documented over like a  few months we're talking like decades